well Russian authorities are opening
more military enlistment centers near
border checkpoints in an apparent
attempt to draft men trying to flee the
country new officers have been set up
acrossings like Kazakhstan which has
taken in over a hundred thousand
Russians since reservists were mobilized
to fight in Ukraine now President Putin
has admitted that some people were
called up by mistake
soldiers from the region died in Ukraine
and opposition to mobilization is strong
but elsewhere in Russia protests and
attacks on conscription centers
underline the growing anti-mobilization
sentiment the call-up has been running
everything but smoothly
President Vladimir Putin admitted that
mistakes had been made
many issues are emerging during the
mobilization it's necessary to fix all
the mistakes and avoid making them again
in regards to citizens who for example
are eligible for deferment
it concerns fathers of many children or
people suffering from chronic diseases
or those who are above the draft age
the Russian leadership say the draft is
only a partial immobilization only for
men with previous Army experience but
the exact amount of the new recruits has
not been made public opposition Russian
media estimate that as many as 1 million
Russians might have been called into the
army
the mobilization has brought out many
other challenges too
even those who are willing to fight fear
they won't be equipped adequately by the
Army in this shop in Chelyabinsk
recruits try to buy whatever they can
mobilize reserves get what the
government provides they receive winter
and summer clothes and shoes the rest
depends people are buying flashlights
for themselves there are also not enough
sleeping bags and mats for everyone
while it's unclear who exactly will get
drafted within the current decree many
choose to leave the country out of fear
of being called to service in Georgia
authorities say around 10 000 Russians
are crossing the border every day
I have escaped the mobilization I don't
want to die for the regime
I don't think it's legal basically it's
Criminal
other countries with land borders to
Russia have also reported thousands of
Crossings since the mobilization was
announced but they are already growing a
very of the large number of arrivals
EU member State Finland close the border
for Russians with tourist Schengen visas
at midnight making it even more
difficult for many to flee mobilization
journalist Peter koslov joins us from
Riga Peta you're in Latvia what what has
the reaction been there to Russia men
Flink in Scripture
well this here the reaction is a little
bit different because the fleeing of
Russian people not only demand the
possible possible conscripts but also
women started here very massively after
the beginning of the war in uh in the
end of February and Latvia and the other
Baltic States became one of the first
initiatives and hardliners to stop the
fleeing of Russians here one of the
reasons is because here in Latvia is a
quite valuable part of russian-speaking
population was before the start of the
war after the collapse of the Soviet
Union so the authorities fear that the
um the possible income of new Russians
it could destabilize the situation
could you give us an idea if this
botched call-up of reservists in Russia
could destabilize Putin's regime in any
way
this is a very crucial crucial moment
for Vladimir Putin and the situation in
Russia
the analysts say that after the decision
of starting the mobilization The
Unofficial contract between the Russian
society and President Putin was broken
the contract which was of course not
written it was it was meaning that the
Russians have become the safety the
security and the right to uh to live
their personal lives but they had not to
intervene in politics but today as we
see and as we understand this contract
was thrown into the rubbish bin because
the people from ordinary Villages from
small towns and from the capitals have
been being contributed to the Army and
they are being very very rapidly sent to
the uh to trainings and to to the
positions of Russian army in Ukraine
journalist Peter koslov in Riga thank
you very much for joining us here on DW